Oh, no, no, bread is Good.
Mark, you're not just invincible.
You're also like,
Earth's best food cooking, man.
Pretty impressive. What? Oh, no.
I just work here.
I don't actually make the food.
Next time.
Also constructive criticism.
Do not put these green things in here.
These are gross. Yeah.
Hey. So did you ever find Urath
Yeah, of course.
I found it very, very quickly.
Very easily.
Yellow skies, purple grass. And get this.
That bird was there, too. Just like these.
Who would have guessed, huh?
You never found it?
No, no, not even close.
I hope they're okay.
I think about them quite a bit, honestly.
But how about you?
What do you been up to? It's been a while.
I think everyone agrees it's been, like,
a little ridiculous how long it's been.
Hey, I've been busy. Doing what?
Well, I've been busy
writing, designing,
storyboarding, voice acting, composing
in between, including publishing.
I've been covering the whole thing
and all that for,
you know, roughly thousands of shots.
So it's kind of a lot.
Sure. Yeah.
Although, like, 90% of that, if I'm being
honest, sounds completely made up.
But the real question is
when are you going back out there?
The world needs more invincible.
Oh, it's coming.
Hey. Yeah, I know, but, like,
a specific thing would be nice.
Oh, okay, fine.
The world will get more invincible
in late 2023.
All right.
Okay, I'll take it.
Late 2023.
Perfect.
Sure.
So 2023.
Is that like, one of your years?
You know, our planet,
they all have different systems
of keeping track of time.
Like they go around their stars,
different speed.
But the way you set that number makes it
sound
soon is it soon. I really want it to be soon.
Welcome back, Everyone is Charlie.
They dropped in Invincible Season
two Teaser Trailer Video.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs
and references
and what's going on during season two.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
I will be doing
episode videos for season two,
just like I did for season one.
The scene in the trailer
they release just has Mark treating Alan
the alien to burgers at Burger Mart,
where he used to work
until his powers manifested during episode
one in season one.
After the events of Episode eight,
after they met an Alan, the aliens
explained to him
who he is, where he came from,
and how he mistakenly came to Earth.
Like that's the whole joke in the trailer
is that he just keeps coming back to Earth
because he can't find the planet
that he was supposed to go to.
The whole idea is that Alan,
the alien, read the instructions
on the planet
that he was supposed to go to arrest
wrong in mistakenly came to Earth
and that's how he came to meet Mark.
And it was just a coincidence
that he didn't side with his father
in the other village.
Viltrumites in conquer earth you
it winds up being a huge turning point
in the war against the Vitrumites.
The whole idea is that the Viltrumites are the villains.
It'd be like if Superman,
the Kryptonians were evil and wanted
to conquer the rest of the universe.
So this is all about Mark
working with Alan the Alien,
the Coalition of Planets
to slowly take down the Viltrumites.
Very slowly, though
it is like so much stuff
that has to happen before that goes down.
There's several more huge built
for Mike characters
that they'll eventually face
during season two, along with multiverse
versions of Mark and other villains
Multiverse villains just in general.
In their joke about how long it's
been like ridiculously long
since they checked in is a reference
to how long the hiatus
has been between season
one and season two.
Mark's replies
Show the script for season two episodes
where things eventually
pick up in the next part of the story.
In the comics, this is a scene of Mark
facing the surviving immortal character.
That's why they call him the immortal,
because he is immortal.
They show a montage of Adam Eve, Steven
Yeun behind the scenes recording episodes,
making it sound like
Mark has been animating season
two episodes all by himself in Alan
the Alien, pressing them on a specific
Season two release date, which they say in
the trailer is late 2023 this year.
When they say that, they probably mean
Fall 2023, like October to December.
Season
two is supposed to be eight episodes
they did renewed for season three as well.
So they're also working on season three.
I think the idea is that
they can get season three out by next year
and we want to wait like two more years
between seasons again.
Right now
it sounds like they're
going to try and drop it by late October,
maybe a little bit before that
so they can get all the episodes out
by the end of the year.
Robert Kirkman
also dropped the teaser back in 2021
where he talks about Engstrom
Levy showing up
and becoming one of the main villains
for that part of the arc.
But obviously there'll be
many other villains that show up
during the different episodes.
The really cool thing about his character
is that he's a multiverse villain.
So the way Robert
Kirkman talks about the future of the show
is that they'll continue
to escalate with each season.
So just in terms of world building,
they'll be
getting into multiverse territory
with alternate versions
of invincible other universes
where things went down very differently.
They'll also be getting
into the coalition of planets more as Alan
the alien teased in their big war
against the evil Viltrumites and what's
going on in other parts of the universe.
They used the flagstones during season one
to tease a little bit of the multiverse
because they came
from an alternate dimension
where time moves a little bit differently.
But Angstrom levy is like the fullest
expression of the multiverse concept.
The comic book timeline for his story
is just a little bit different
because it overlaps with the Mauler twins
in some of the things
that they did during season one.
So they might change it just a little bit.
But Robert Kirkman did confirmed
that they would continue to change
the comic book story for the TV episodes.
They did the same thing during season one,
but without getting too deep
into his storyline, basically he breaks
the maulers out of prison to help him
create another mind transference device
that they normally just use
for cloning themselves.
Only Angstrom.
Levy doesn't want to clone himself.
He wants to accumulate the sum total
of all knowledge from as many alternate
realities as possible.
So even without the Mauler's
help, he's able to construct a device
that allows him to travel
to alternate realities.
He uses that to assemble a team
of other versions of himself
from alternate realities,
then modifies the Maulers device
so that it allow him to transfer
or basically download all the knowledge
from all of his copies into his own mind,
making him this all knowing villain.
But as he activates
the device, Cecil learns
about what he's doing and calls Mark in
to stop him in the Maulers.
And even though they played
for a little bit of comedy, like
Mark is still learning to be a superhero.
So he kind of fumbles
his way through the fight.
But he's so powerful
that they're not really a threat to him,
so they just play it
for some funny moments
and he inadvertently breaks Angstrom
Levy's machine while it's in the middle
of downloading all the knowledge
from his multiverse duplicates.
And even though it kind of works,
it does download a lot of their knowledge
into his mind.
It also winds up
leaving him horribly disfigured.
And he swears revenge on Invincible
and uses the multiverse to pursue that.
He's a really cool character,
but as you can see,
they played the character
for a lot of comedy.
But the other cool
thing about his character
is that through him,
they get to do all these other
different versions of Invincible
because it's the multiverse.
Like during his first appearance,
he's grabbing another angstrom levy,
from a version of Earth where Invincible
actually went to the dark side
and agreed to help his father Omni-Man
take over the planet.
He's grabbing this alternate angstrom
levy right in the middle of this same
fight scene that he had with his father
in the finale of the TV show.
Only on this version of Earth, Invincible,
instead of saying no
to him, actually said, Yeah, viltrumites
and they start to take over the planet.
So eventually they wind up doing a bunch
of really cool looking, evil iterations
of Invincible from different universes
through angstroms run as a villain
in the comics, culminating
in what they call the Invincible War.
It's sort of like their version
of a reverse Marvel's
Secret Wars type of event where
instead of a bunch of alternate reality
heroes teaming up with each other,
it's Angstrom Levy unleashing
a team of evil versions of Invincible
on the main universe.
One of the other big things
that Robert Kirkman was hyping up during
season two was the coalition of Planets.
Now Allen the Alien.
explained a little bit to mark
what was going on with that
and what their main goal is trying to
build support in the rest of the universe
to rebel against the build from ice
and get rid of them
like the rest of the universe versus
the Viltrumites.
You learn a little bit more about the day
to day with the coalition of planets
and Alan the aliens back story.
He explained a little bit of his backstory
during season one,
but I think we'll just get more of him
during season two.
That whole arc in the comics is called
the Viltrumite War.
That's sort of like their big Avengers
Infinity War type of moment
where they actually do fight
the Viltrumites.
They do have a plan,
but it doesn't go down exactly
the way you think it would,
was the premise.
Some of the other Viltrumites
during season two.
There are many that you see
during the comics,
but after Omni-Man conquest
is one of the next big ones
that mark winds up going against.
And then eventually
you work your way up to three
big, who's sort of the de facto
leader of the village.
For my people,
there's also a lot of guilt
for my history that they only brushed over
really quickly during season one.
They'll probably get deeper into that
during season two and season three.
There are a lot of other minor villains
that you see during those end credits.
Scenes like you see the Maulers
get re-arrested locked back up.
Like I said, they're a big
part of the Angstrom levy plot.
So either they'll break them
back out again and use it for some comedy
or they'll find some other way
for Angstrom levy to get their technology.
You see the flagstones
preparing to attack Earth again
and declaring revenge on Omni-Man
because he basically wiped out
their entire planet.
That was probably one
of the coolest moments too, watching him
go ham on an entire planet in the span
of what seems like just a couple of weeks,
just long enough for him to grow
some facial hair.
There we see the Titan has taken over
as the new boss of the city
after they got rid of his old boss.
It just seems like he's
going to continue to be a thing.
But it's sort of like the devil you know.
Doc seismic is back
and they've escalated his threat.
He's controlling
a whole bunch of magma golems this time.
Probably one of the bigger teasers,
though, is Cecil
inspecting the new upgraded re-ani-men,
because they actually did give Omni-Man
a run for his money.
They overwhelmed him for a little bit
before he took them down.
But these are still very early versions
of these that they continue to iterate on.
It sort of like Terminators,
like they get better and better over time.
And even though they portray
the viltrumites,
it's like they're totally unkillable
except other build from
it's like a built from
I could kill another village for my
in battle bees could probably kill
a vulture might look he almost kills Mark
for the most part
the way they portray them
during season one,
they're relatively on kill able.
Eventually they do find vulture
my weaknesses that they can
exploit also through the coalition
of planets storyline as well.
But some of that stuff
like the viltrimute war storyline
they might not get into too many seasons
later like season three, season four.
Some of that stuff is way
further ahead in the comics.
For the most part,
it just seems like Anstrom
Levy will be the main storyline
for season two.
Maybe that'll culminate in the season two
finale with them doing a version
of the Invincible War storyline,
even though it sounds really epic,
a bunch of alternate reality
versions of Invincible
fighting the main version of Invincible,
it only lasted for single issues.
It was actually pretty short war.
And even though Omni-Man took off
at the end of the episode,
like he finally decided
that he did care about Mark
and he wasn't going to kill him, so
he had to find some way to make up for it
because his current marching orders
from Thragg from the village for my command
structure were to take over other planets,
and he had chosen to take over Earth.
That had been his mission
for the last 20 years
in order to make up for that failure,
for not taking over Earth,
he has to go find another planet
to take over.
And that leads to another big storyline
in the reveal of another big character.
So without getting too deep into that,
I don't know if they're going to wind up
doing
the Oliver character during season two,
if that'll be a big reveal
or WTF moment and maybe like the finale,
or if they'll see that for season three.
But if you have not read the comics,
it actually ended in 2019,
so you can actually read the entire
comic book story.
Now, they won't wind up doing
everything from the comics
and they will change a bunch of stuff,
but it is still a really cool story
and it'll give you a pretty good idea
for some of the stuff
that they'll do in future seasons.
But the big takeaway
is that with each season
they will continue to escalate
the conflict.
Things will get bigger, more galactic,
crazier and crazier.
Obviously Season two is just pushing
that into multiverse storytelling,
but there's a bunch of stuff coming up.
I'm doing
the Last of US episodes on HBO right now.
I'll put links to that in the description
below.
The Mandalorian Season 3 episodes
are going to start really soon.
I'll be doing videos for that as well.
Marvel's Secret Invasion
is going to happen. After that.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Everyone click here for that
Rebel Moon Netflix trailer
and learn about Zack Snyder's
version of a Star Wars movie.
And click here
for my new King, Ant-Man and the Wasp
Quantumania Trailer Video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.